So the question is,
how do you differentiate the utility of
behavioral slash psychotherapeutic
treatments for conditions like
depression versus medical treatments?
Okay,
so the first thing I would say is don't
underestimate the utility of medical
interventions.
Depression is a cat,
a catastrophe.
It carries with it a very high suicide
rate and it also levels people out and
it's really hard on their families and
so and it and it's physiologically
extraordinarily damaging.
And so if you're in a depressive state
and it's severe,
you can try an antidepressant.
You'll know in a month if it works,
if it works well,
maybe it'll help you get your life
together.
Like we could say,
well maybe you're depressed because your
life isn't very well together.
Could be.
Sometimes people are depressed,
their life is just,
it isn't fine because no one's life is
fine.
Everyone's life is a tragedy,
but sometimes people have their lives in
order,
as much as you could expect anyone to
have.
They have friends,
they have an intimate relationship,
they have a career that they like,
you know,
they're,
they're qualified,
industrious people working hard on what
they're doing.
And,
and,
and really playing a minimum number of
games with themselves and they're
terribly depressed,
antidepressant man that's sometimes that
will just fix it.
And so hooray,
you were biological entity.
If,
if there's something out there that can
help you strengthen yourself so that you
can prevail.
Great.
And you know,
people,
you hear,
everyone takes antidepressants,
you know,
everyone's taking them.
It's like no one takes those bloody
things without serious consideration.
Half the time I spend with my clients
who are depressed is often the two years
long attempt to get them to tentatively
try an antidepressant because there are
so guilty that they're relying on an
external crutch to sort out their lives
that they can't even tolerate it.
But you know,
I say,
well look man,
what if you had diabetes?
You're not going to take your insulin.
It's like you got stressed.
He blew out at your weakest point.
That's what happens when you get
stressed.
If there's something out there that
might help you,
it's like try it for God's sake.
You'll know in a month and you'd just
stop if it doesn't work.
Now,
having said that,
you want to do a multidimensional
analysis,
it's like,
well,
do you have any friends?
Do you have an intimate relationship?
Are you pursuing one?
Do you have a reasonable career or you
as educated as you are intelligent?
Do you have something useful to do with
your time outside of work?
Do you have a drug or alcohol problem?
Are there other behavioral issues like
sleep dysregulation and lack of eating
that are contributing to the pathology?
You want to differentiate all of that
and wherever you can make a behavioral
intervention so much the better,
but sometimes too,
you're dealing with people whose lives
are so racked that they don't even know
where to start.
They're different than the ones who have
everything in order to say and you say,
well,
try this man.
Maybe you won't cut your throat in the
next month because if your dad,
it's going to be hard to work with you,
and so,
so medical interventions,
anything.
If you're sick,
you do what it's necessary to get better
and you leave your pride behind.
If you.
If you have to,
and that says nothing about the utility
of the behavioral interventions,
you want to hit the problem with
everything you have at your disposal,
but some antidepressants especially
especially for people whose lives are
together and who are depressed,
antidepressants can be absolutely
miraculous.
So you know when you hear about the
clinical evidence in their favor being
iffy,
and that's partly because the diagnosis
of depression isn't very well
formulated.
It's very different to have a terrible
life than to be depressed and
antidepressants can only help you so
much if you have a terrible life.
So
yeah,
you want to stay inside this little map
because it's working.
You want to get from point a to point a
to point b and this is good.
This indicates that you are moving
forward.
That's the first thing it indicates and
the second thing it indicates,
which is even more important,
and you'll never hear this from
behavioral psychologists,
is that your map is correct.
So every time you move a little bit
forward and something that you want
happens,
it says,
oh,
the game I'm playing is the right gate.
And so not only does the reward indicate
progress,
it indicates that the frame within which
progress is being calculated is the
right frame,
and that's good because it's the frame
that makes things irrelevant and you
want them to stay irrelevant.
So if you don't move forward and you
start to question the frame that's way
worse than merely not moving forward.
You get a bad exam grade,
what do you think?
What the hell am I doing in university
anyways?
It's like probably that's not the first
place you should go with that piece of
information.
And you think,
well,
why?
Why is that worse?
Well,
as far as I can tell,
your map of view as university student
is a comprehensive representation.
It tells you what you should do every
day.
It kind of tells you where you're going
in the future.
And if something emerges as an anomaly,
you get worse grade than you expected
and you blow that whole map.
It's like,
okay,
what have you been doing for the last
four years?
What kind of high school student were
you?
How clueless are you about how you're
arranging your future?
What's your identity going to be if
you're not going to be a student,
where are you going to end up in five
years?
It's like,
so it's like a that little grade,
that bad grade is like a portal through
which snakes can crawl and that's
exactly how you respond to it.
Especially if you open the door too
much.
Well,
maybe this means that I shouldn't be in
university.
Well,
one of the rules is don't you want to.
You want to constrain the anomalous
event to the minimal necessary domain.
It's really,
really important.
You want to do that when you're arguing
with your partner,
which will do all the time.
We have an argument,
well,
I should never have married you.
It's like,
no,
that's not the first response.
That's a bad response,
or here's a really good one.
You've always done that sort of thing
and you always will.
It's like,
oh good,
great.
It's like the only answer to that is to
hit someone because like you're done,
right?
Your your life,
that you've always been like that.
There isn't a chance that you can be
repaired and none of it is acceptable.
It's like the person's gonna fight with
you right away because what else are
they going to do?
So what you want to do is you want to
minimize.
It isn't rationalization.
You want to say,
okay,
this person did something that disrupted
our joint map.
Okay,
what's the smallest possible thing they
could do to put it back together?
And you have to know,
well,
we need to make a plan so you don't do
it again.
Or we need to have a discussion so that
you know that it wasn't a good thing to
do,
but I'm not going to go after your whole
character.
I'm going to say when I come home
and you're watching TV,
just come to the door and say hello,
not,
don't you love me?
Or something like that.
It's like,
no,
you just have to walk to the door and
like give me a hug or something,
and then that's good enough,
and so then the other person might be
able to tolerate that much corrective
information.
Maybe if you're kind of Nice about it
and you also understand that they're
probably going to have something equally
horrible to say about you in the next 15
minutes because you're going to do
something stupid so so you don't wanna
you don't want to open the door so that
every possible snake comes crawling
through because that's a pathway to
depression and you actually see that
happening in depressed people is that
every small event produces a cascade
through their entire value system and
they end up saying,
well,
that's just another reason that I should
jump off a bridge and they really see it
that way.
It's really awful because they've got no
defenses.
It's like,
well,
I didn't do so well in this course.
It's like I'm going to get a bad mark
and they or an exam,
I'm going to get bad mark in the course
that's going to screw up my ability to
finish my degree.
I'm never going to get into the field of
my choice.
It's just another piece of indication
that I'm useless and that life isn't
worthwhile.
Bang,
I'm going to jump off a bridge and if
you're really depressed,
it's like each of those things hits you
with the certainty of truth.
It's really not good and so you want to
be careful.
You want to be careful about walking
down that pathway when you make a
mistake,
you think,
okay,
what's the narrowest framework of
interpretation within which I can.
I can understand this.
That will require minimal behavioral
change to decrease the probability that
it will happen.
Again,
it's mental hygiene fundamentally.
Yes.
Yeah.
We'll get to that.
That is the next question.
It's because they don't exist in
isolation,
so and that's another thing.
Frequently when when you,
when you hear behavioral accounts of
cognitive processes,
they generally only focus on it as if
it's an isolated thing.
It's not.
It is.
It's scalable,
it's scalable.
A bunch of ways it scalable temporarily
because what you do now is associated
with what you'll do tomorrow and that
with what you'll do next week and so
forth.
So it has to be scalable temporarily and
it's also scalable socially.
Right,
so it has an effect on you that has an
effect on your family that has an effect
on the community and so forth,
and so you don't want to take.
It's very difficult to think through the
effect of your auction and all those
scaling level simultaneously,
but,
but you have mechanisms that allow you
to do that and we'll see.
I think that the sense of let's assume
that you're not lying to yourself
constantly so your head isn't full of
chaos and garbage and you have
reasonable relationships with people in
the world.
I think that this is leaping way ahead.
I think that your sense of meaningful
engagement with what you're doing is the
psychophysiological marker,
that you're acting in a way that takes
all of the stacked representations into
account simultaneously because you're,
you're,
you're like,
you're trying to figure out where you
are and you might think,
well,
that means where I am in this room,
but look,
this room is not a simple thing,
right?
It's nested.
It's,
it's a subset of the university that's a
subset of society.
It's a subset of your life.
The room is a complicated thing and you
need to figure out where you should be
in the room and you can't do that shit
surely with perception because all you
see is me and some of the wall,
right?
It's you got this little narrow,
this little narrow portal and so you
can't really rely on your perceptions to
Orient you,
but you do Orient Yourself and I think
what you do is you.
It's engagement.
It's like does this seem meaningful and
deep and engaging?
Yes.
Then it's an indication that it's
serving multiple masters,
similar caneously,
so both maybe both socially and also
temporarily.
And so I think the sense of meaning is
actually an instinct that orients people
in time and space.
It's not an EPA phenomena.
It's the most fundamental form of
perception and that's the only
optimistic thought that I've ever been
able to derive from psychology is that
that actually could be true.
It could be that the sense of meaning is
an orienting reflex and that would be
wonderful if it was true because it
would make it real,
you know,
and it's one of the,
the one of the devastating elements of
nihilism is something like,
well,
who the hell cares what you're doing,
what differences are going to make in a
million years?
It's like your sense of meaning is just
an illusion.
You know,
you're,
you're limited creature in a limited
place and nothing you do really matters.
It's like that's a powerful argument,
especially if you're an objective
materialist in a reductionist.
It's a killer argument,
but it looks to me like it's wrong.
It's actually wrong because meaning
looks to me like it's an actual
phenomenon.
It does say that you're,
you're positioned properly between chaos
and order.
Something like that.
It's a real so.
Well.
So we'll see.
We're going to develop that argument
because if,
if it's real,
you want to know that because it gives
you something to stand on.
You know,
maybe it's as real as pain,
but it's not.
It's something positive and you need
something positive that you can rely on.
All right,
so and psychoanalyst,
I think,
err too much on the side of the subject.
They tend to think that too much of you
is inside of you and too little of you
is outside of you and part of the reason
I believe that is because of my clinical
experience.
I love the psychoanalyst man.
They're brilliant.
They're brilliant or deep.
They grapple with real problems like
with the problems.
When people have real problems and I
mean profound problems.
They're really profound.
Moral problems or problems of good and
evil really know there are things going
on in their family that are so terrible
that well that there are.
There are some times fatal,
you know,
lie upon,
lie upon lie for decades and decades and
decades.
It's awful
and that's not exactly inside them.
It's out there in the world and lots of
the people that I see,
very famous critic of psychology,
I can't remember his name,
but I probably will
criticized the practice of psychology
quite effectively in the believe in the
early sixties.
The Myth of mental illness by Thomas
says zed,
a s zed,
it's classic.
You should read it if you're interested
in psychology,
read it like it's a classic,
and he basically said most people have
problems in living.
They don't have psychological problem,
and so I've experienced despite my love
for the psychoanalysts,
very frequently what I'm doing as a
therapist is helping people have a life
that would work.
You know,
and you can parameterize that.
It's like,
what do you need?
How about some friends that people kind
of like that.
How about an intimate relationship with
someone that you can trust that maybe
has a future.
That'd be good.
How about a career that puts you in a
dominance hierarchy somewhere so at
least you've got some possibility of
rising,
some possibility of stabilizing yourself
and our schedule and a routine because
no one can live without a routine.
You just forget that if you guys don't
have a routine,
I would recommend like you get one going
because you cannot be mentally healthy
without a routine.
You need to pick a time to get up
whatever time you want,
but pick one and stick to it because
otherwise you disregulate your circadian
rhythms and they regulate your mood and
eat something.
In the morning.
I had lots of clients who have that
anxiety disorders,
hired one client who was literally
starving,
very smart girl.
She was very little that she liked.
She kind of tried to subsist on like
half a cup of rice a day.
She came to me and said,
I have no energy.
I come home.
All I want to do is watch the same movie
over and over.
What?
Like,
is that weird?
And I thought,
well,
it depends on the art work.
You know,
it's a little weird,
but whatever it's familiar,
you're looking for comfort.
So I did an analysis of her diet.
It's like three quarters of a cup of
rice.
It's like you're starving,
eat something,
you know,
you'll feel better.
So she modified her diet and you're all
are anxiety went away and she had some
energy.
It's like,
yeah,
you got to eat.
So schedule.
That's a good thing man.
Your brain will.
Thank you for it.
It will stabilize your nervous system
when it's a bit of a plan.
That's a good thing.
You need a career.
You need something productive to do with
your time.
You need to regulate your use of drugs
and alcohol.
Most particularly alcoholic is that does
eating a lot of people,
um,
any your family,
like the family,
you have,
your parents and all that,
it'd be nice if you all got along.
You could work on that.
That's a good thing to work on.
And then,
you know,
you probably need children at some
point.
That's life.
That's what life is.
And if you're missing,
you know,
you may have a good reason to not be
operating on one of those dimensions.
It's not mandatory,
but I can tell you that if you're not
operating reasonably well on four,
I think I mentioned six,
if you're not operating reasonably well
on at least three of them,
there's no way you're going to be
psychologically thriving.
And that's more pragmatic in some sense
than psychological,
right?
Human beings have a nature.
There's things we need and if we have
them,
well that's good.
And if we don't have them,
well then we feel the lack.
So behaviorists,
behavioral psychologists concentrate a
lot more on that sort of thing.
No,
it's practical.
It's like strategizing.
Make a career plan,
figure out how to negotiate because
that's bloody important.
Figuring out how to say what you need,
figure out how to tell the truth.
He figured out how to listen to your
partner in particular because if you
listen to them,
they will actually tell you what they
want and sometimes you can give it to
them and maybe they'll return the favor.
And if you practice that for like 15
years,
well then maybe you're constantly giving
each other what you want.
Well Hooray.
That would be good.
And then there's two of you under all
circumstances and it's better to have
two brains than one because people think
differently because of their temperament
mostly.
And so the negotiation is where the
wisdom arises and it's part of the
transformation,
the psychological transformation that's
attendant on an intimate relationship
and one of the fundamental purposes of a
longterm intimate relationship.
So we're starting to be able to put the
traits to sort of nail the traits down
to their underlying biology with regards
to neuroticism.
Well,
if you're high in neuroticism,
you're more sensitive to anxiety and
that's regulated at least in part by the
hippocampus and and generated in part by
the Amygdala.
There's another part of the brain called
the [inaudible] aqueduct will gray.
That seems to be associated with the
experience of pain and pain is quite a
complex phenomena.
Depression is pain.
Like grief is pain,
like social isolation is pain.
Like disappointment is pain.
Like there's anxiety components to that
too.
And so neuroticism seems to be something
like threshold for activation in those
negative emotions systems.
So if you're higher in neuroticism,
one unit of uncertainty might produce,
let's say three units of
psychophysiological response.
Whereas if you're lower in neuroticism,
one unit of uncertainty might produce
one unit of psychophysiological
response.
It's hard,
obviously that's a simplified schematic,
but there's variability because if
something unexpected or threatening
happens to you,
it isn't obvious how upset you should
get one answer,
what might be a brush it off?
It's nothing.
Now their answer might be it's a bloody
catastrophe and often when something
uncertain or threatening occurs,
you don't have enough information at
your disposal to make a full
determination of the potential impact of
this,
of the circumstance,
especially if it's uncertain and so then
you have to guess at how upset you
should be and where you are on the
normal distribution with regards to
trait neuroticism.
Say that sort of determines what your
guests on average is going to be.
So you know the other with
conscientiousness say it might say,
well,
how hard should you work?
Well,
that's a really difficult question.
If you're going to die tomorrow and then
you probably shouldn't work very hard
today at all.
So one thing you might say is that the
degree to which you should work hard is
dependent on your assumptions about the
stability of the future.
We actually know this to be true because
if you put people in wildly uncertain
circumstances,
they discount the future,
which is exactly what you should do,
right?
It's only makes sense to store up goods
for future consumption if the future is
likely to be very similar to the past
and the present.
You need a stable society for that and
conscientiousness only works in in a
stable society because all you do
otherwise,
if you're piling up goods,
which is Kinda what conscientious people
do,
is leaving them there for the criminals
to take or waiting for the next chaotic
upheaval to wipe out everything that
you've stored and so even
conscientiousness is a kind of guess,
hardworking people say,
well,
you know,
a sacrifice the present for the future.
That's great as long as the future is
going to be there and you can predict
it,
but if it's not going to be there and
it's unpredictable,
then the right response is take what you
can take right now while the getting's
good.
Now you know,
obviously there are troubles with that
too.
It,
I'm speaking,
you know I'm,
I'm offering rough rules of thumb,
but I'm trying to provide you with some
indication of how and why these
difference in value structures exist
because they're are applicable in
different environments.
You know,
sometimes in a dangerous social
environment,
it's not obvious that being an
extroverted person is a good idea
because extroverted people,
they stand out,
especially if they're extroverted and
creative,
right?
Because not only are they noisy and
dominant and assertive,
they're also colorful and flamboyant and
provocative,
but happens to people is that as they
move towards zero,
positive feedback loops get set up so
they're more likely to hit zero,
and as they move away from zero positive
feedback loops get set up so that
they're increasingly more likely to move
away from zero.
So here's an example.
Let's say a,
you're not doing too bad,
so maybe you're in the middle of the
normal distribution,
then you lose your job.
Okay?
And so let's say you're a conscientious
person and we could say just for the
sake of argument,
that you lose your job because of mass
layoffs in your company.
So it has nothing to do with you.
It's fundamentally,
it's just like luck of the draw
basically.
But then what happens to you?
Well,
if you're conscientious,
you're gonna,
you're gonna.
Go after yourself pretty hard.
So you're going to add,
especially if you're also high in
neuroticism,
it's going to depress you to lose your
job,
and maybe you're in a situation where
you just for one reason or another,
you don't have that many other
opportunities.
Now maybe you should look for them,
but maybe you're in a depressed strata
of the economy or you're geographically
located somewhere that makes moving
difficult or so on and so forth.
You know,
so,
but you lose a job and then you start to
get depressed because of that.
Well then as you start to get depressed,
you know it decreases the probability
that you're going to look for a job,
but it also maybe starts to put stress
on your family and it also starts to
decrease the probability that you're in
gonna.
Engage in positive social interaction.
So now not only are you unemployed and
suffering from economic stress,
but your marriage is starting to suffer
and you're starting to isolate yourself
from your friends.
And then of course,
as your marriage suffers in the stress
builds up,
then that's gonna.
Make you more depressed.
And that's going to keep you even
farther away from your friends and
that's going to decrease the likelihood
that you're going to have enough
positive emotion and enthusiasm to look
for another job.
And then you know,
maybe you want to add a bit of a
drinking problem too,
that just for fun and you can see that
you can get a spiral going that's just
taken you down.
Right?
And there's all sorts of things because
lots of times people conceptualize,
let's say,
you know,
you're unemployed guide,
you go to counseling and you get a
diagnosis of depression.
And the thing about a diagnosis of
depression,
it's sort of like the assumption is
there's something gone wrong with your
psychological structure.
It's like if you're unemployed and
you're,
you're depressed,
it isn't obvious at all that the problem
is in your head,
you know,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it doesn't.
If it isn't even obvious that it's a
psychological problem,
it's just a problem and problems can
take you out.
And so you know,
if you're unemployed and you're under
economic stress,
your marriage is starting
to shake and you're isolating yourself
from your friends and you're less likely
to be motivated to go look for a job.
You can sort of think about that as a
depressive spiral,
but you can also think of it as a
conspiracy in some sense of external
forces that are arguing you into the
ground and we don't tend to
conceptualize psychological disorders
that way,
but we should because lots of times when
people are suffering from something that
you could describe in psychological
terminology and depression is a very
good example of that.
It isn't obvious that there's something
wrong with them.
Psychologically.
Often they are in trouble and there
isn't a category in psychological
diagnosis for client in serious trouble.
But my experience has been almost
without exception,
that the people that come to see me come
to cv because something's gone wrong
with their life,
not because they have a psychological
problem.
Now you could say,
well,
there are psychological inadequacies
such as they might be,
are interfering with their ability to
recover or maybe even served as
precursors to,
you know,
increase the probability of the
catastrophe.
And so a well functioning personality
has all the micro routines in place.
That's actually something that you help
people with if you're a behavioral
therapist because one of the things you
assume if you're a behavioral therapist
is that sometimes the reason people
aren't doing things is because they
don't know how.
You know,
sometimes maybe the person is depressed
but potentially high functioning.
They got all the damn micro routines.
They're well socialized,
they're just dormant.
You got to get them awake again and
implementing them.
But sometimes you get someone in your
practice say who's just been neglected,
like you cannot believe,
right?
The parents never paid any attention to
them or maybe just punish them every
time they did something good.
That's really fun.
And then,
you know,
they didn't make friends and so they're
really,
really
vague and,
and,
and poorly articulated.
And so then what you do is you work at
the bottom of the micro routines and get
them to practice building up all these
little attributes that they didn't build
up and you know,
one of the things you can think about in
terms of character development is so now
maybe understand something about your
own personality.
You might say,
well,
what could you do to improve your
personality?
And the answer is develop some of the
micro routines on the other side of the
personality distribution.
So if you're disagreeable as hell,
maybe you could start learning how to do
nice things for people and without
actually works by the way.
So if you take disagreeable people who
are depressed and you get them doing
nice things for other people,
their depression tends to lift.
But then by the same token,
if you're agreeable,
then you should practice doing some
things for yourself and being more tough
minded in your negotiations.
So you can sort of place yourself on
the,
on the personality trait,
distribution.
You know you're extrovert.
It's like,
okay man,
learn to spend some time with yourself.
Right?
You're low in openness.
Well,
try reading a book that's outside of
your,
you know,
your sphere of interest now in that,
um,
if you're conscientious,
well you should probably learn how to
relax occasionally and so forth.
So you can,
I think partly what you're doing as
you're developing your personality is
not moving the mean much,
the average where you know,
where you're located,
but you're extending the standard
deviation so that you're a bigger bag of
tricks than you were before.
And I think you can practice that
consciously.
It's like you're hyper orderly.
It's,
well get a dog,
you know,
dogs are messy,
horrible things,
you know,
it's just what you need if you're hyper
orderly because they're going to leave
hair everywhere and force you to live
with it.
And so,
okay,
so and so this is sort of,
you right?
This is your personality.
It's this connect collection of routine
sub routines that you've turned into a
hierarchy.
And then there's something at the top of
it.
And that's,
that's a big question.
Like what the hell should be at the top
of the hierarchy?
Because that's the ultimate question of
unity.
And the clinicians would say,
well,
it's the self actualized person,
or it's the self or something like that,
you know,
that's,
that's the,
that's the implicit and perhaps explicit
ideal that you're aiming for.
And you might say,
well it does such thing exists that I
would say,
well,
do you admire people?
Because that's your answer,
right?
Do you despise people while you like
some people and you don't like others?
You respect some people,
you don't respect others while you're
acting out the notion that there's at
least an implicit ideal,
you do the same thing when you go to
movies,
you know you know who the hero is,
you know who the bad guy is.
You're acting out the proposition that
there's some sort of value hierarchy and
there's some sort of manifestation of it
that's coherent across time.
So you appear to believe that and you
know you are driven at least to some
degree by your own inner ideals.
And so you tend to answer the question,
is that real with an affirmative?
And if you don't,
there's catastrophic consequences.
Nietzsche and the existentialists were
very good at detailing.
That's like,
let your value hierarchy disintegrate.
Well then what?
Well,
part of it is nihilistic chaos,
who that's not so much fun,
and then there's the alignment of
nihilistic chaos with the intrinsic
desire that someone will come along and
tell you what to do.
Right?
So what happens is if you let this
devolve,
you end up with nihilistic exit,
not with nihilistic chaos or the demand
for,
for the tyrant to come forward.
And we've had that happen lots of times
and it doesn't seem to have gotten that
well.
So.
Alright,
well,
so what happens when you,
you lay out these little routines in the
world at different levels of analysis.
Well this is how your emotions function
broadly speaking,
what you're aiming at something and that
this is an oversimplification,
which is why I want to show you this
right?
When I show you this.
Assume that it's made out of that,
right?
It's just a schematic,
oversimplification because even if let's
say that I'm trying to do something as
simple as walking towards the door,
I mean that the action of walking
towards the door is predicated on the
existence of all the sub routines that
enabled me to propel my body across time
and space and like there's.
That took a lot of internal organization
to get that right.
It's a traumatized now and so you can
treat it like it's invisible,
but implicit in any one of these
structures is this entire structure and
you actually see this in therapy very
frequently to get.
One of the things that I've figured out
over the last years is this is a good
proposition,
so no,
it's pretty self evident that life is
has got its rat's nest of miseries and
that's for sure and maybe you could even
make a categorical statement that life
is mostly a rat's nest of misery.
You know,
when you could make a pretty powerful
argument for that,
but then there's a counter question
which is,
well,
what if you tried not to make it any
more miserable than it had to be?
Right?
Then what then what would it be like,
and my suspicions are,
is that Laura had misery.
I would suspect that most of that misery
would go away because it's the
unnecessary misery that really brings
you down.
You know?
It's like,
well,
if someone has cancer,
it's like,
that sucks,
but it's not like.
It's not like you can say,
if only we had done this differently,
then that wouldn't have happened.
But when someone's out like torturing
you in a malevolent way,
or maybe you're doing the same,
you can always ask yourself,
well,
it's really,
is this really necessary?
Is this just like a useless add onto the
miseries of life?
That's what disheartens people,
and so even in your own life,
if,
if you,
if you aren't suffering from self
imposed misery and you're only suffering
from an escapable misery,
maybe you could handle that and who you
could.
You could survive.
You could bear it and even maybe without
becoming irredeemably corrupt.
So the goal would be,
well yeah,
life is a rat's nest of miseries and
maybe it has no ultimate meaning.
We could say that if we're feeling
particularly pessimistic,
but it still leaves one question open,
which is if you didn't do everything you
could to make it worse,
how good could you make it be?
And the least answer is,
well,
it could be tragedy,
but maybe not hell,
and I think that's right.
I really believe that that's the most
pessimistic proper statement.
The worst case outcome in the worst of
all possible worlds is that your life
could be tragic but not hell,
and that's blood better than hell,
right?
It's,
it's.
And you think I could give you an
example of the difference.
You're at your mother's death bed.
Well,
that's tragedy.
Here's another scenario.
You're out of your mother's death bed
and all you,
you and all your idiot siblings are
arguing.
Well,
that's the difference between tragedy
and hell and you might be able to
tolerate the first circumstance and
maybe it would even bring you closer
together with your family members.
The second one,
no one can bear that.
You walk away from a situation like
that.
Sick of yourself and sick of everything
else too.
And you know,
it's often the case that tragic
circumstances bring out the dragons
because the stress is high and all those
things that people haven't dealt with,
they don't have the energy to repress
and,
and all the bitterness comes pouring
forward.
So like,
seriously man,
it is.
So that's actually a good.
It's a rough lesson,
but it's a good hallmark for figuring
out whether or not you're.
You've got yourself adjusted properly
and in relationship to your siblings.
It's like if you all gathered around the
bed,
if someone close who was dying,
could you manage it?
And if the answer is no,
it's like,
well put your life together because it's
going to happen and you should be the
person who's there that can do it and do
it properly.
And then maybe you'd find that it isn't
the sort of thing that will undermine
your faith in life itself.
And I've seen,
I've seen both of those situations,
you know,
ugly,
ugly situations,
murderously,
ugly situations.
And then they're opposite where people
have had terrible things happen to
happen to them as a family.
And you know,
they pulled together and
they rebuild their damn ship and they
sail away.
So that seems to me to be a lot better.
That makes,
you know,
uh,
when the flood comes,
right?
Well,
okay,
so the same thing.
Question emerges.
Well,
who are you?
you could say
you're this plan.
That's what people usually,
that's how people usually identified.
Maybe they have no plan at all and
they're just in chaos,
right?
That's like being in the belly of the
beast.
They're nihilistic and chaos.
They have no plan.
They're just chaos itself.
And that's a very dreadful situation for
people to be in.
Or maybe they conjure together a plan
that's their identity.
It's kind of fragile and they're holding
onto that with,
with everything they've got.
It's the little stick would that they're
floating in the ocean,
clinging to,
you know.
And so they're identifying really hard
with that plan.
That's what happens when you're an idiot
log has that.
You're identifying really hard with that
plan.
The problem is if something comes up to
confront it,
well,
how do you act when you can't let go
with the plan?
Because you drown,
then you clean to it rigidly.
Well that's no good because then you
can't learn anything.
Then if that's you,
you're a totalitarian,
you're going to learn anything.
You're going to end up in something
that's close enough to hell so that you
won't know the difference and you might
drag everyone along with you.
Now it's happened plenty of times,
right?
It's the whole story of the 20th
century.
It happened over and over and over,
and it happens in people's states.
It's to happens in their business
organizations.
It happens in their cities,
it happens in their provinces,
it happens in their states,
and it happens in their psyches all at
the same time.
You can't blame the manifestation of
that sort of thing on any of those one
levels.
It happens when a society goes down that
way,
it goes down everywhere.
At the same time,
it's not the totalitarians at the top
and all the happy people striving to be
free at the bottom.
It's not that at all.
It's totalitarianism at every single
level of the hierarchy,
including the psychological and so you
don't want to be the thing.
You don't want to be in chaos,
that's for sure,
but you don't want to be the thing that
clings so desperately to the raft that
you can't let go.
When someone comes to rescue you,
right?
You don't want to be that,
so then you think,
well,
exactly what are you?
You're not the chaos.
You're not the plan.
Maybe you're the thing that confronts
the obstacle,
and I would say that's the categorical
lesson of,
of psychology in so far as it has to do
with personal because that's what you
always teach people in psychotherapy.
I don't care what sort of
psychotherapist you are,
you're always teaching them the same
thing.
You're the thing that you're not.
You're not the plan.
You're the thing that can confront the
obstacle to the plant and then when you
know even further that the obstacle is
not only an obstacle,
but opportunity itself within your whole
view of the world can change because you
might think,
well,
I've got this planned.
Something came up to object to it.
It's like it's possible that the thing
that's objecting has something to teach
you that will take you to the place
where you develop it,
even better plant and it's a nice
framework to use.
It's like,
are you so sure that this is a problem?
Is that the only way that you can look
at it or is it an opportunity?
I mean,
I'm not trying to be naive and
optimistic.
There are some things that's pretty hard
to extract gold from some dragons and
maybe the death of a family member is a
good example of that,
but in even in a situation like that,
I can tell you that it's an opportunity
for.
It's an opportunity for maturation,
that's for sure.
And the thing is you might say,
well,
it's pretty miserable to go to be
digging for gold when someone's falling
into the grave.
Well,
if they really love you,
first of all,
that's what they'll want you to do,
and second,
you're going to make their death a lot
more palatable experience for them.
If you're someone who can be in the room
and be helpful instead of being,
you know,
quivering in the corner and feeling that
the entire world is collapsing in on
you.
I mean that's another.
You want to be the useful person at the
funeral.
How's that for a goal?
That's a good goal,
man.
You know that you've got yourself
together in a situation like that
because you're gonna be active and maybe
you want to be the person on whose
shoulder people cry.
That'd be a good goal and it's Kinda,
you know,
I don't like being naively optimistic.
So when I tell you to get your life
together,
I'm not going to say roses and sunshine.
It's like,
that's,
that's Pablum for fools.
But it really is something to be the
reliable person at a funeral.
There's this idea in union psychology
called the circumambulation and you had
this idea that you had a potential
future self which would be in potential
everything that you could be and that it
manifests itself moment to moment in
your present life by making you
interested in things and the things that
you're interested in.
Are the things that would guide you
along the path that would lead you to
maximal development.
Now it sounds like a metaphysical idea
or a or a mystical idea even,
but,
but it's not.
It's not.
It's a really profoundly biological
idea.
The idea is something like,
well,
your set up so that you're automatically
interested in those things that was
fully expand you as a well adapted
creature.
There's nothing radical about that idea.
How well what else could possibly be the
case unless there's something
fundamentally flawed about you that is
what the situation would be.
It's kind of interesting to think about
how that would be manifest moment to
moment,
but the idea is something like,
well,
your interest is captured by those
things that lead you down the path
of development.
Will that better be the case?
Okay,
so that's fine.
And so there's some utility in pursuing
those things that you're interested in.
And that's the call to adventure,
let's say so.
And the call to adventure takes you all
sorts of places.
Now the problem with the call to
adventure is like,
what the hell do you know?
You might be interested in things that
are kind of warped and bent,
and often it's the case that when new
parts of people manifest themselves and
grip their interest,
say they do it very badly in shoddily
and so you stumble around like an idiot
when you try to do something new.
That's where the fool is the precursor
to the savior from the,
from the symbolic perspectives.
Because you have to be a fool before you
can be a master.
And if you're not willing to be a fool
and you can't be a master,
so,
so you're gonna get it's an error error
ridden process.
And that's also laid out the old
testament stories because the first
thing that happens to all these
patriarchal figures when God kicks them
out of their father's house when they're
like 84,
is that they,
they run into all sorts of trouble.
And some of it's social and some of it's
natural and some of it's a consequence
of their own moral inadequacy.
So they're fools and.
But,
but the thing that's so interesting is
that despite the fact that they're
fools,
they're still supposed to go on the
adventure and that they're capable of
learning enough as a consequence of
moving forward on the adventure so that
they straightened themselves out across
time.
And so it's something like this and this
circumambulation that young talked about
was this continual,
we'll return to this,
this continual circling in some sense of
who you could be.
You might notice,
for example,
that there are themes in your life.
You know,
when you go back across your
experiences,
you see,
you kind of have your typical experience
that sort of repeats itself and there
might be variation on it,
like a musical theme,
but it's like you're circling yourself
and getting closer to yourself as you
move across time.
That's the circumambulation.
Now you remember that for a sec because
we'll go back to it.
Okay?
So imagine that something glimmers
before you.
It's an an interest that's daunting and
you decide,
well,
first of all,
you're paralyzed.
You think,
well,
how do I know if I should pursue that?
It's probably a stupid idea,
and the proper response to that is,
you're right,
it probably is a stupid idea because
almost all the all ideas are stupid and
so the probability that as you move
forward on your adventure that you're
going to get it right the first time is
zero.
It's just not going to happen.
And so then you might think,
well maybe I'll just wait around until I
get the right idea and which people do.
Right?
So they're like 40 year old,
13 year olds,
which is not a good idea.
So they wait around until it's waiting
for Godot until they finally got it
right.
But the problem is you're too stupid to
know when you've got it right.
So waiting around isn't going to help
because even if it's the perfect
opportunity manifested itself to you in
your incomplete form,
the probability that you would recognize
it as the perfect opportunity is zero.
You might even think it's the worst
possible idea that you've ever heard of
anywhere,
highly likely,
highly likely.
So.
So you ha.
There's a niche,
a niche are called that will will to
stupidity,
which I really liked,
so because he thought of stupidity as
being,
you know,
it's,
you have to take it into account
fundamentally and work with it and so
and so.
You can take these tentative steps on
your pathway to destiny and you can
assume that you're going to do it badly
and that's really useful because you
don't have to beat yourself up.
It's pretty easy to do it badly.
But the thing is it's way better to do
it badly,
the not to do it at all.
And that's the continual message that
echoes through these historical stories
in genesis.
It's like these are flawed people.
They should have got the hell out of
their house way before they did.
And they go out and they stumble around
in tyranny and famine and self betrayal
and,
and violence.
And,
but it's a hell of lot better than just
rotting away at home.
And that's the,
that's great.
So that's good.
And so why is that?
Well,
okay,
so you start your path and you think
that you're heading towards your star
and so you go in that direction and then
because you're here,
the world looks a particular way,
but then when you move here,
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having
made that voyage and so what that means
is that now that thing that glimmers in
front of you is going to have shifted
its location because you weren't very
good at specifying it to begin with and
now that you're a little sharper and
more focused than you were,
it's going to reveal itself with more
accuracy to you.
And so then you have to take a.
You know,
it's almost like 180 degree reversal,
but it isn't because you know you've.
I mean you've gone this far and that's a
long ways to get that far,
but that's a lot farther than you would
be if you just stayed where you were
waiting.
And so it doesn't matter that you
overshoot continually because as you
overshoot,
even if you don't learn what you
should've done,
you're going to continually learn what
you shouldn't.
Keep doing,
and if you learn enough about what you
shouldn't keep doing,
then that's tantamount at some point to
learning at the same time what you
should be doing.
So it's okay.
So it's like this.
Now what's cool about it though,
I think is that as you progress,
the degree of overshooting starts to
decline,
right?
And that we know that there's nothing
hypothetical about that.
As you learn a new skill,
like even to play it play a song on the
piano for example,
you overshoot madly,
you'd making all sorts of mistakes to
begin with and then the mistakes
disappear.
There's a great ted talk,
I think it was about this guy set up a
really advanced computational recording
system in his home and recorded every
single utterance his young child made
while learning to speak.
And then he put together the child's
attempts to say certain phonemes and put
them in list and you can hear the child
deviating madly to begin with.
And then after hundreds and hundreds of
repetitions just zeroing right in on the
exact phoneme.
So you know,
you might not know this,
but when kids babble because they start
babbling when they're quite young,
they babble every human phoneme
including all sorts of phonemes that
adults can't say,
and then they die into their language so
that after they learn,
say English,
then there's all sorts of phonemes they
can no longer here or pronounced,
but to begin with,
it's all there,
which is really quite interesting,
but so they see as they learn a
particular language,
they zero in on the proper way to
pronounce that and their errors minimize
and every time you learn something,
that's how it is and that's really
useful to know too because it means that
it's okay to wander around stupidly
before you fix your destination.
Now you see that echoed in exodus,
right?
Because what happens is that the
Egyptians or the Hebrews escape the
tyranny,
which is kind of whatever you do
personally and psychologically.
When you escape from your previous set
of stupidly held and ignorant and
stubborn axioms,
it's like away from that tyranny.
It's like,
great.
I freed myself from that.
Well then what?
Well,
you think,
well now I'm on the way,
it's no,
you're not.
Now you're in the desert where you
wonder around stupidly,
you know and worship the wrong things
until you finally organize yourself
morally again and head in the proper
direction.
So that's worth knowing too because you
think,
well,
I got rid of a lot of things,
baggage,
excess baggage that I didn't need in my
life,
and now everything's okay.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
You've got rid of a whole set of
scaffolds that were keeping you in place
even though they were pathological.
Now you have nothing and nothing
actually turns out to be better than
something pathological,
but you're still stuck with the problem
of nothing,
and that's well,
that's exactly why exodus is structured
the way that it is.
It's that you escaped from materiality.
It's hooray.
We're no longer slaves.
Yeah,
well now you're nihilistic and lost.
It's not necessarily an improvement,
but it is,
but it is the pre.
See,
it's also useful to know that because
you can also be diluted into the idea
that imagine that you're trying to
become enlightened,
which might mean to turn all those parts
of you on that could be turned on.
You think,
well,
that's just a linear pathway uphill.
You know,
it's just from one success to another.
It's no,
it's not.
It's like here you are and you're not
doing too badly in the first step is a
complete bloody catastrophe.
It's worse and then maybe you can pull
yourself together and you hit a new
plateau and then that crumbles and
shakes and bang.
It's worse again and so because part of
the reason that people don't become
enlightened is because it's punctuated
by intermittent deserts essentially by
intermittent catastrophes,
and if you don't know that well,
then you're basically screwed because
you go ahead on your movement forward
and you collapse and you think,
well,
that didn't work.
I collapsed.
It's like,
no,
that's par for the course.
It's not indication that you failed.
It's just indication that it's really
hard and that when you learn something,
you also unlearn something and the thing
you unlearned is probably useful and
unlearning it actually is painful.
You know,
let's say if you have to get out of a
bad relationship,
it's like not every,
not any real.
There isn't any relationship that's a
hundred percent bad,
and so when you jump out of it,
well maybe you're in better shape,
but you're still lonesome and
disoriented and you don't know what your
past was and you don't know what your
present is and you don't want know what
your future is.
It's not.
That's why people stay with the devil
they know instead of you know,
looking for the devil they don't know
so,
so anyways,
the fact that you're full of faults
doesn't mean you have to stop and thank
God for that.
That's a really useful thing and the
fact that you're full of faults doesn't
mean that you can't learn and so you can
pause it in an ideal and you're going to
be wrong about it,
but it doesn't matter because what
you're right about his positing,
the ideal moving towards it,
if the actual ideal is
conceptualized perfectly well first
surprise,
because like what are you going to do?
That's perfect.
So it doesn't matter that it's
imperfect,
it just matters that you do it and that
you move forward.
So that's really,
that's really positive news as far as
I'm concerned because you could actually
do that,
right?
You can do it badly.
Anyone can do that.
So that's,
that's useful.
Okay.
So like if you were an efficient person,
you would have just done that but you're
not.
But who cares?
You know,
you still end up in the,
in the same place and maybe the trip is
even more interesting.
Who knows?
Probably too interesting.